hey this is press to
Walker this video covers two delightful
number Theory
questions problem
one what is the remainder when
2023 to the power of
2023 is divided by
35 I thank sunth for the
suggestion problem
two what is the units digit of the
flooor of the fraction 10 ^ of 20,000
divided by 10 ^ of 100 +
3 this is from the 1986 putam
competition question
A2 pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these
problems let's solve problem one
so one way is to use the binomial
theorem you can write 2023 as 2030 -
7 this is equal to a multiple of 35 -
7 so we can write it as 35k minus 7 we
take this to the power of
2023 and we can apply the binomial
theorem to 35 K - 7 raised to power of
2023 it's going to look very complicated
but it will simplify
tremendously notice that all of the
terms that have 35k raised to some power
that's greater than zero will be a
multiple of
35 so all of these terms can be
summarized as 35j because there will be
some multiple of
35 so then we just have the final term
which is the opposite of 7 to the power
of
2023 what this calculation shows is that
2023 to the power of
2023 will have the same remainder when
divided by 35 as the opposite of s
raised to the power of
2023 so we just need to work out this
problem so now we'll do some more
magic so how can we rewrite this this is
also equal to --7 * 7 to the^ of
2022 and that is equal to 7^ 2 raed to
the^ of
101 but 7^2 is equal to 50 -
1 so now we'll again apply the binomial
theorem we have -7 multiplied by this
entire binomial expansion of 50 -1
raised to the^ of
101 we'll simplify this
tremendously all of these terms will
have 50 to some power that's greater
than zero so all of these terms will be
some multiple of 50 and the sum of many
multiples of 50 will also be a multiple
of 50 so we can write this as
50n the final term will be equal
to1 so this simplifies to be -7
multiplied 50 n - 1 which is equal to
-350 n + 7 but -350 is a multiple of
35 so this has a remainder of exactly
seven it'll be a multiple of 35 + 7
therefore we figured it
out 2023 to the^ 2023 is equivalent to
-7 to ^ 2023 mod 35 and and that is
equivalent to 7 modul
35 therefore the remainder is seven and
that's one way to solve the
problem another method is to use modulo
arithmetic now 35 is equal to 7 * 5 so
let's consider
2023 modulo 7 and modulo 5 now 2023 is a
multiple of seven and a 2023 is three
more than a multiple of 5 so 2023 is 0
mod 7 and it's 3 mod 5 so from there we
can raise both sides to the power of
2023 so 2023 to the power 2023 is
equivalent to Z mod 7 and it will be
equivalent to 3 to the power of 2023 mod
5 so let's simplify the right hand
side now we'll perform some mathem magic
3 to the^ of 2023 is equal to 3
multiplied by the quantity 3^2 to the
power of
101 3^2 is equal to 9 which is
equivalent to -1 mod 5 so this is
equivalent to 3 * -1 to the power of 101
mod
5-1 to an odd power will
be1 so this is equivalent to -3 mod 5
which is of course equivalent to 2 mod
5 so where do we go from here
from the first equation we have 2023 to
the power of 2023 is equivalent to Z mod
7 so this is going to be a multiple of
seven so it'll be equal to 7 * k for
some integer
K but we know that 7 is equivalent to 2
mod 5 so this means this is equivalent
to 2K mod 5 so now we have two different
Expressions we have 2K mod 5
and we have 2 mod 5 this means that K is
equivalent to 1 mod 5 in other words K
is equal to 5 * J + 1 for some integer
J we can now substitute that into
7K so 2023 to the^ of 2023 is equal to 7
multipli by the quantity 5 J + 1 which
is equal to 35 J + 7 so we figured it
out we have a multiple of 35 + 7
therefore 2023 to the power 2023 is
equivalent to 7 mod
35 it has a remainder of s when divided
by 35 and that's the
answer now let's solve problem
two so how do we even approach this
question let's first rewrite the
fraction so it's a little a little bit
easier to read let U be equal to 10 ^ of
100 so we'll take this fraction first
we'll rewrite the numerator 10 ^ of
20,000 as 10 to the power of 100 all
raised to the power of 200 now wherever
we see 10 ^ 100 let's write U so this is
U to the^ of 200 ided by U + 3 we'll now
do one more trick we'll divide the
numerator and the denominator by U so
this is equal to u to the^ of
199 / 1 + 3 over
U so how does this help
us well recall if you have a common
ratio that has an absolute value of less
than one the formula for the sum of a
geometric series 1 + r + r 2 plus so on
is equal to 1 / 1 - R now in R fraction
we don't have 1 minus r we have 1 + r so
if we let R be equal to the opposite of
X we end up with the fraction 1/ 1 + x
and we get an alternating series 1 - x +
x^2 - x cubed and so on so we'll apply
this formula to the
question we'll let X be equal to 3 over
U and of course 3 over U will be a
positive number that's less than one so
we can apply this
formula so we pull out the factor U to
the^ of 199 and we multiplying this by
1/ 1 + 3 over U so we will apply this
formula now so we have 1 - 3 U plus the
sare of 3 U and so
on so now we need to distribute this
term U to the^ of
199 we're going to do it in three
different parts the first part will have
U to some power that's greater than
zero so for the first 199 terms we have
U the^ 199 minus 3 * u^ 198 and this
goes all the way down to the opposite of
3 raised to the^ of 198 multiplied by U
so all of these terms have U to some
positive power the very next term will
have U to the^ of0 that's equal to one
so this this is -3 raised to the^
199 all of the terms after this will
have U raised to a negative power or u
in the denominator so the very next term
will be plus -3 raised to ^ 200 / U then
we have plus -3 raed to^ 201 / U ^2 and
so on so let's analyze the sum in three
different
sections so the first section will all
be the positive powers of U now U is
equal to 10 the^ of 100 so these are all
powers of 10 so we take all of these
terms modulo 10 this will be equivalent
to 0 mod
10 then we'll look at all of these terms
where U is in the
denominator this is going to be an
alternating series so of course the sum
of all of these terms will be less than
the very first term the very first term
is -3 ra to the^ of 200 / U we'll just
rewrite this term in a little bit
different way so we see that it's equal
to 9/ 10 raised to the^ of 100 now this
is a positive number that's less than
one so what does that mean this is
basically going to be a fractional part
of this number now notice if it was
negative it actually would change the
very last digit of the number because
you would be going down by one but but
we know that it's a positive number
that's less than one so all of these
terms will not affect the very last
digit of the number that we're trying to
figure
out so we have three different sections
of this number let's let this entire
number be equal to
a so we take the floor of a it'll be the
blue sum plus -3 raised to the^ 199 and
we eliminate all of this fractional part
the positive number that's less than one
further more if we take this number
modulo 10 we eliminate all of the parts
that are highlighted in blue so the
floor of a is equivalent to -3 raed to
the^ of 199 mod 10 so the very last
digit of the floor of a will be exactly
what -3 raed to the^ of 199 mod 10
is so we just need to figure this out
this is a very manageable
calculation so -3 raised to the^ 1
that'll be-3 3 which is equivalent to 7
mod 10 if we multiply by -3 again this
will be equivalent to 9 mod 10 multip by
-3 again this is equivalent to 3 mod 10
multip by3 again and this is equivalent
to 1 mod 10 so we need to figure out -3
raised to the^ of
199 so we can rewrite 199 as 4 * 49 + 3
so we rewrite this exponent we then
break this up and then we use power to
the
power so we now know that -3 raised to
the power 4 that will be equivalent to 1
mod 10 and -3 raised to the^ 3 will be
equivalent to 3 mod 10 so we can
substitute those in so this is
equivalent to 1^ of 49 * 3 mod 10 1^ 49
is just 1 so this is equivalent to 3 mod
10 therefore the units digit of the
floor of a will be equal to three and
that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time